y fue servidor de tres presidentes
activos seguidor de barack obama y quien
sufrió y también disfrutó de los más
altos cargos en el gobierno y en el
ejército de eeuu cuál es el legado que
deja powell a su país
bueno han descrito gracias por la
invitación
compadre es uno de los individuos más
respetados en la historia de la política
y las fuerzas armadas de eeuu como bien
está ha llegado a tener cargos de lo más
alto en el país en las fuerzas armadas
siendo un soldado de carreras de 35 años
y después fue
nombrado a tener cargo diplomático más
alto de la nación que es este que está
afectado bajo el gobierno del presidente
george w por ahí yo creo que es un señor
que tiene respeto tanto por sus maneras
diplomáticas como sus formas de
militares combinando esos dos mundos y
mejorando la política estadounidense en
varios aspectos yo creo que es un hombre
que vamos a extrañar y un hombre que
merece mucho respeto por el público y
sin embargo hay un episodio de su
carrera que él mismo lamenta y le quiero
preguntar si ensombrece este legado que
usted nos dice su defensa a la invasión
a irak en su momento
bueno sí yo creo que claro hay una
mancha en su legado en ese sentido que
una peor decisión que han tomado eeuu en
su política exterior es la inversión de
irak pero también ha habido muchos
libros cuentos periodísticos
investigaciones y diferentes relatos que
han demostrado que con el pago estaba
muy en contra de ese decisión obviamente
que él al final día se puso de acuerdo y
hizo su presentación ante las naciones
unidas sobre el tema de armas de
destrucción masiva en irak sin embargo
hay mucha gente que han contado bajó
mucho la credibilidad de que el
colombiano estaba a favor de esa
decisión y lo luchó internamente en
euromillones de george wars hay una
doctrina que se conoce dentro de las
fuerzas armadas que se llama el doctrina
ko
específicamente por el colegio y se
denomina esto porque dice que cuando los
dados a meterse en un conflicto en el
exterior debe hacerlo con un favorable
opinión pública con suficiente fuerza
militar y solo en la condición que es
una amenaza creíble entonces eso creo
que sobrepasa la mancha de que es cuando
decidió apoyar la inversión de eeuu e
irak
bueno y ya para decirle le quiero
preguntar de cómo se debe hacer la
lectura de ese cambio que tuvo su
posición política hace poco más de una
década después de estar al servicio de
tres gobiernos republicanos llegó a
apoyar a barack obama a hillary clinton
y a joe biden e hizo una fiera crítica
contra el ex presidente de donald trump
y poner claro que no tuvo favores con
los últimos gobiernos republicanos
posiblemente presidente del trump sin
embargo yo creo que también demuestra
que no era partidario por decir o se era
republicano por la mayoría de su carrera
política y también su carrera
diplomática sin embargo él también
siempre pensaba más independiente en
ciertos temas y cuando tenía sus
opiniones lo vocal o decirlo si enfrente
mente sin miedo de que le van a votar
del partido le van a aislar
políticamente a se ha hablado con su
conciencia pues de estar de acuerdo con
sus últimas declaraciones porque si yo
no estoy de acuerdo con mucho que ha
dicho finalmente en su política sin
embargo le respeto por hablar libremente
de sus ideas y de mantenerse fiel a sus
convicciones